>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Mari Nakahara: Thank you very
much for joining today's lecture
by Thomas Burns regarding his
National Cherry Blossom Festival
Poster Process.
My name is Mari Nakahara,
the curator for architecture,
design, and engineering
at the Library's Print
and Photograph division.
And I also am today's
program coordinator.
This program is one of the 2018
National Cherry Blossom Festival
official events, cohosted by
the Library's Asian division,
as well as Print and
Photograph division.
The Library began to participate
in the National Cherry Blossom
Festival starting from 2012,
when we celebrate
the 100th anniversary
of the cherry blossom
tree gift from city
of Tokyo to Washington, DC.
Since then, we continue
hosting events and the programs,
coinciding with the National
Cherry Blossom spring event
every year.
So this is to pursue one
of the Library's goals
of providing general
understanding
of American cultural,
intellectual, and social life,
and of other peoples
in the nation.
I'm hoping that these
lectures and events will
in the future inspire a greater
interest in Japanese culture,
the US-Japan relationship,
and also the Library's
diverse collections
in the general public,
including K-12 students.
As a matter of fact, in
addition to today's lecture,
the Library will host a K-12
program called Japanese Culture
Day this Saturday April
7, between 10 to 3
at the Young Readers Center with
children's book author Tad Hills
from New York City, as
well as the Spring Fling,
a pop-up exhibition exploring
the sight, sound, and the smells
of the spring season
through treasures
from the Library's vast
collections, including a host
of cherry blossom
related materials.
The Spring Fling will be
held on April 6, 7, 13,
and 14, between 10 to 4.
Events are free of charge.
I hope many of you can come
back and enjoy these programs.
The National Cherry Blossom
Festival has been one
of the international
renowned events in DC.
What I as a curator
for design look forward
to every year is an exquisite
poster which is created
by a selected designer.
I gradually cultivated my dream
to collect these posters as part
of the Library of
Congress collections.
And my curiosity to learn how
each designer gets inspired
to design the National
Cherry Blossom poster has
naturally grown.
Today I'm extremely excited and
pleased to invite Thomas Burns
and introduce the National
Cherry Blossom historical
posters generously donated
by the National Cherry
Blossom Festival last year.
I believe you have already
enjoyed five posters outside
of this room, but we will be
showing rest of the posters,
historical posters,
at the Prints
and Photographs Reading
Room after this lecture.
The room is just
around the corner.
We will guide you where it is.
So please attend and just
enjoy the rest of the posters.
Borrowing this opportunity,
I want to express my deep
appreciation to Diana Mayhew,
president of the National
Cherry Blossom Festival,
and Lillian Iversen
and their colleagues,
and then also Martha Kennedy,
my colleague and the curator
of Popular and Applied Graphic
Arts, who corroborated with me
to acquire these posters.
Let me introduce Thomas Burns.
Thomas Burns grew up in
Gainesville, Florida,
and received a bachelor of
fine arts in graphic design
from the University of Florida.
After pursuing an MBA in
supply chain management
at Michigan State University, he
relocated to Atlanta, Georgia,
to work for a major
telecommunications company.
Artistically, he
remained unfulfilled
and eventually created his
own freelance studio in 2007.
His illustrations
are fun, whimsical,
and richly detailed
piece like this.
He created the flyer to us
that still boasts a
very handmade quality.
His areas of expertise
include editorial advertising
and children's illustrations.
His work has been
exhibited in New York,
Los Angeles, and Atlanta.
Mr. Burns is currently a
professor of illustration
at the Savannah College of Art
and Design, Atlanta, Georgia.
Finally, please join me
welcoming Thomas Burns.
[ Applause ]
>> Thomas Burns: Thank
you, Mari, and thank you
to the Library for inviting
me here, and thank you guys
for coming out today to
hear this little talk
about this process
for the 2016 poster
for the National
Cherry Blossom Festival.
And I think Mari kind of
went through my whole life.
I have a little like -- yeah, I
know, I have this little section
about my background, so
I'll go through it again.
Okay, so this is
me long, long ago,
when the dinosaurs
roamed the earth.
I'm way older than I look.
I went to school and got
a degree in graphic design
from the University of Florida.
And you can see how
happy I look there.
Coming out of school
with my portfolio,
I'm ready to go conquer the
world and do some artwork,
but my family said, you got to
go get a real degree in business
because -- and if you
notice, my expression starts
to go a little bit -- yeah.
Business is where
it's at, you know.
So you can, you know, have
a long fulfilling life
as an accountant or
something like that.
So I got a degree in
supply chain management
from the University of -- or
Michigan State University.
And I ended up working
for the phone company.
And I kid you not, my little
cubicle was between the bathroom
and the janitors closet.
I did not see sunlight
for eight hours a day.
It was not fulfilling to me.
So of course my solution
is to go back to school
and get another degree.
So I got my MFA in
illustration from SCAD,
the Savannah College
of Art and Design.
They have an Atlanta
campus, a Savannah campus,
and one in France I
think, and then Hong Kong.
So you can see the expression
changes, I'm much happier.
I open a little studio.
Started doing some freelance
work, a lot of advertising,
packaging, some editorial stuff.
And then I started teaching
and I grew this beard,
which I'll probably get rid of.
So now it's gone again.
Okay, so that's just
a little bit about me.
So this was the type of
work that I was doing
when I had my own
little studio kind
of post college,
graduate school.
You can see, this is editorial
stuff and then a little bit
of children's stuff here, and
it sort of has this kind of fun,
whimsical feel to it, kind of
brighter colors, and it's sort
of rooted in kind of that
mid-20th century aesthetic of,
you know, Warner Brothers
cartoons or Tex Avery
or Hanna-Barbera and
maybe a little bit
of Mary Blair in there.
If you're familiar with "It's
a Small World" at Disney,
that's that sort of
Mary Blair aesthetic.
It's a 1950s -- she was
a '50s conceptual artist
for Disney World.
And I think this is what
caught Lillian Iversen --
she's in the audience today.
The director of programming
at the National Cherry
Blossom Festival.
And so she sent me an
email, gave me a phone call,
something like that, and
said, hey, what do you think
about doing the poster
for this year's 2016 --
for this year's Cherry
Blossom Festival?
And I was like, oh, that
sounds amazing, let's do that!
So generally what
happens in big projects
like this is you get
a creative brief.
And part of the brief
was, you know,
they wanted to own
springtime that was anchored
in the annual flowering
of the trees
and retelling the narrative
of the awe-inspiring beauty
of the trees in bloom.
And then of course
something that can be utilized
on merchandise, you know, for
that memory of participant.
And how many people have come
to multiple Cherry
Blossom Festivals?
More than 10, more than -- okay.
This is our second one,
it's just, it's fantastic.
And thank you guys for the
weather today and tomorrow
but not so much on Saturday,
because it's supposed
to snow; is that right?
A lot of snow?
Okay, so the way this
starts for me, this process,
is I go all old school and
I get into my sketchbook.
Even though my work is
finished digitally --
I do everything in
the computer --
I love to get in my sketchbook
with some pen and ink and paper
and get down and dirty and do
some traditional materials.
And I'll do some board
association stuff, you know,
that's kind of for me
just to kind of plot
out the major points of, you
know, what should be connected
and the feeling and the
ideas that should go into it.
And then this is what
my thumbnails look like.
And you can see some
of the cherry blossom
thumbnails over on the right.
The stuff on the left
could be something
from an editorial project
or any ideas that I've had
that I just sort of try
to get out of my head
or get onto some paper.
Otherwise they tend to
evaporate and you're like,
I had this great idea but I
don't remember what it was.
So as long as it gets
down on some paper
and there's some record of
it, you know, you can sort
of save it and work with it.
And you know, maybe you're
working out some kind
of solution to some
visual problem.
And these are just some
more thumbnails, you know.
There was this a
project about frogs.
So I'm doing a lot of frogs
and I'm trying to figure
out what this frog is
going to look like.
Is he in a race?
Is he, you know -- what is
he -- I don't know, whatever.
It's a bunch of frogs.
Okay, so these are some of
the beginning thumbnails
for this poster that's
out front.
So they're really small.
They're maybe about an
inch and a half big.
They're pretty simple at
this stage, but you can kind
of tell exactly what's going
on in each one of these.
So there's the capitol with
the reflected cherry blossom
and a little bit of typography.
Or maybe the capitol's made out
of flowers or cherry blossoms.
Or maybe there's the
monuments with the, you know,
blossoms coming out of it.
Or the capitol popping
open an explosion
of flowers, which I always love.
And then maybe the typography
ends up in trees, you know,
it's sort of woven into it.
Or there's a large flower
with birds and caterpillars
and maybe some butterflies
and ladybugs
and then some more
little tiny ones.
Just trying to work out
what this is supposed
to look like visually.
So this is the one I really
liked at the beginning stage.
She's kind of laughing.
She's like, because this
is not what the final piece
looked like.
And I know there were a couple
other illustrators maybe
under consideration
for this at this point.
So I took this way
beyond probably
where it should've been.
I took it almost to finish, and
I was like, this looks awesome.
I got some hand type in here.
And there's a couple
color variations.
And I showed this to Lillian.
And I think I even mocked it
up on some products, you know.
I was like, this better happen.
I was like, look, we can put
it on T-shirts and coffee cups
and tote bags and key chains
and all kinds of stuff.
And I sent it off to Lillian.
And she was like, this
looks great, except --
let's go back and do
some more thumbnails.
Because I don't know about the
capitol popping open the things
exploding out of it, so that
might be a little weird.
So we did some more thumbnails,
some more exploration
on this stuff.
And these are just a little
bit beyond what a thumbnail
might be.
These are value comps.
Some kind of working out,
you know, where the darks
and the lights and the
greens and the blues
and that kind of stuff will go.
So you can see this
sort of swish that kind
of comes out of the capitol.
And then the idea of that
second one where it swishes
around the capitol and ends in
that larger dominant flower,
and then the third
one where it switches
to the Washington Monument.
And then you can see the kind
of difference between three
and four where it's just a
subtle difference between that.
So the one that was picked
out of here was this one.
And I think that type actually
ended up moving down lower.
So some basic design
principles that go into even
at the small size
of these thumbnails.
This is like super design
101, the basic rule of thirds.
So if you grid up something,
you know, with three columns
and three rows, you can overlay
it on a piece and kind of figure
out where the major components
of things are going to lay out.
So you can see the
buildings kind of lay
out in the top third, you
know, where those dots are,
and the Washington Monument
sits in the top third
and the swish comes down
and that type drops right
in the middle and
it leads down to
that larger dominant
flower at the bottom.
So really simple kind of stuff.
And then another thing
that's sort of working
in this composition is the
little S swish that goes
through it and leads your eye
all the way down to the bottom.
And then the V that
kind of funnels you back
down to the bottom again too.
So, you know, it's just this is
really basic design principles
about how these things
are constructed.
And this is an example
of another piece that has
that swish that kind
of runs through it,
but it's really obvious
in this piece.
And then this one
maybe not so obvious.
There's a lot of stuff
happening in here.
Except, you know, you can
see where this upside U
and this top U kind of --
the major piece of this
sort of lay on those arcs.
And then maybe one more, you can
see the X, it just drops right
in the middle, you know, sort
of this two-point
perspective kind of thing.
So this stems from my graphic
design background of kind of,
you know, wanting things to
be organized and orderly.
Not all my pieces, you know, end
up like this, but as a structure
to hang your hat on
and do these pieces,
it sort of facilitates
the process.
All right, so then here, this
is actually the finished piece I
think, except maybe the type
changed a little bit at the end.
But then you can see,
you know, how those --
the V shows up and
the S shows up in that
and funnels everything
down to the bottom.
And then -- oops, let
me go back one more.
I'm getting ahead.
And then you can also see
there's one other little
principle kind of happening
in here is this sort of large,
medium, and small idea.
One large dominant flower,
a bunch of medium-size ones,
and then thousands of
little tiny tiny flowers.
So let's go forward.
And I work in Adobe Illustrator.
I'm sure you guys are
familiar with Photoshop.
Everyone's heard of Photoshop,
and you can tweak
things and change things.
And Photoshop lends
itself really well
to mimicking traditional media.
So you can plug in all these
brushes and emulate oil painting
or watercolor or charcoal or
pencil or that kind of stuff
and get this sort
of really hand-done,
traditional look to something.
Adobe Illustrator works
a little bit differently
and it's heavily used in
the graphic design world,
which is my background.
And if you think about it,
Adobe Illustrator works
almost like cut paper.
So all these little
things are layers of paper.
And they can all be repositioned
and resized and tweaked
and turned and manipulated.
And I'll go forward.
So this is what all the
pieces start to look
like when I'm designing them.
And then they can all
sort of be overlaid.
So you can see that green
swish that runs that.
It looks kind of like cut paper.
It has that flat look to it.
And there's thousands and
thousands of layers of pieces
of that cut paper in here.
And you can see the buildings
when I've pulled
them apart here.
You know, they're not
completely finished
because -- if I go back.
They're hidden behind
some other things.
But there's actually
a little bit more
to the buildings and the pieces.
And Adobe Illustrator is very
-- you can manipulate things
and kind of move
the flowers around
and make sure there's
no tangents
when things touch each other
in awkward ways, or there's,
you know, two pink flowers
next to each other that look
like they blend into each other.
So you have a lot of precision
and a lot control over it.
Maybe not so much like in
Photoshop or traditional media,
where once you put that mark
down and you kind of blend it
with other pieces,
it's harder to kind
of manipulate it
and move it around.
And then some typography
was being considered during
this process.
And some little animals
snuck into it,
some little birds
and butterflies.
The capitol snuck into
that bottom right one.
I don't think any of this got --
well, maybe the middle one kind
of got considered near the end.
So then this was sort
of laid out on the --
the major swish thing
where the type went.
It kind of moves around.
And then I think that's the
your regular logo, right?
So then the building
process of this whole thing.
So there's the finished piece.
So if I'm starting with
all that cut paper,
I lay down my sky first,
and add the buildings.
Then started adding the
green river of spring.
And then a bunch of flowers.
And then some more
-- yeah, you can see,
it's kind of a tiny little
-- there's just more stuff
and leaves kind of adding in the
background sort of fills it out.
Then some butterflies.
It's animated --
it's not animated,
I'm just clicking buttons.
And okay, and then the big
flower ends up at the end.
And then there's a subtle shift
here, and I'll talk about that
in a second, where you can
see right around the clouds
and maybe in the green area
where some texture
ends up in there.
And I do bring this into
Photoshop at the end.
And then there's a color
shift here and some
of that typography
ends up at the bottom.
And then that's sort
of the finished piece.
And this is sort of a
blown up detail of that.
And you can see, I bring this
into Photoshop and use some
of those more traditional
brushes that emulate splatters
and gouache and oil paint, and
you can see a little bit of that
down in the corner, and then
it's ending up on the flower.
And it sort of takes
away that really clean,
sterile graphic design look
to it and gives it a more,
you know, sort of humanistic,
traditional feel to it.
And one of the final pieces
to that is I will slip a piece
of old vintage paper
behind the entire piece.
And you can see on the right,
that's just a little
section of it.
And it's, you know, something
out of a book, like an end paper
out of a discarded
book from the library,
or an old comic book that,
you know, has a section
that has some speckled
tone to it
and has yellowed and has aged.
And that slips behind everything
and I let it kind of peek
through the entire design.
And you can see that texture
on the flower and kind
of sit behind in the
green area and the --
yeah, I guess on the flower
and the little green
area in the back.
So then there's the
final design.
I think it's close, except
for the type at the bottom.
And then I do want to mention
that I do teach at SCAD,
the Savannah College
of Art and Design.
They have a campus in Atlanta.
And I've been there
about five years.
And I always tell the students
that this is like Hogwarts.
It's a magical place.
And I know, because they
come in and, you know,
they're just drawing and
they're making magical things.
And I tend to get them right at
the end of their career there --
I teach graduate students
and undergrads but sort
of seniors and high juniors.
So they've kind of gone through
all their techniques classes
and they've learned oil,
pastels, and watercolors,
and you know, all their
perspective drawing
and their life drawing.
And then I get them when it
starts to the application stage.
So we're doing posters.
I teach posters and
advertising illustration
and editorial illustration and
children's book illustration.
And let's see.
And this is what a typical
classroom looks like.
We have like meeting
rooms and tables,
kind of like you would
have in a small agency
or like a bigger company.
And then there's
workstations behind.
And other classrooms have
traditional media tables to get
down and dirty with the
actual physical things.
And we just have such a good
time sitting there and talking
about this stuff
and doing stuff.
And honestly, I may
learn more from them
than I teach them, I don't know.
But at some point I'm just
like, oh, that looks great,
and I'm writing it down, like
how did they do that, I don't --
so I guess that's about it.
That sort of sums up
the whole idea of how
that thing is created and
I guess where I came from.
And I would like to thank Mari
and the Library of Congress
and Lillian and my
family and you guys
for coming out for this.
[ Applause ]
Sorry, did I talk too fast?
Yeah, so now, do you
guys have any questions?
I will -- plenty of questions.
>> How far in advance are you
actually approached about this?
>> Was it maybe about
a year maybe.
>> Over the summer or latest
early fall of the previous year
of the festival that's
forthcoming.
So for 2016, I think I
reached out to you about July.
>> Thomas Burns:
July of '15, yeah.
Because a lot of stuff had to
be done by fall of '15, right?
>> Right.
>> Yeah, to get printed and
advertised on the website
and that kind of stuff, yeah.
>> Typically we get
inspired by the artwork
and then utilize pieces of
it in marketing materials,
all of that starts getting
designed before Christmas.
So that's why we try and -- the
sweet spot is the late summer.
>> Is there an annual
feel to this?
Or is it whatever
they want to do?
>> No real feel, per se.
There might be something or some
words that we try and interject
or propose to the artists to see
how it might resonate with them
and put it into an illustration
or from a artistic rendering.
But it's not as though we
say, oh, 2015, the theme is,
you know, a walk in the
park or anything like that
and say have your artwork
specifically represent
that statement.
But -- so yeah.
>> Thomas Burns: Yeah.
And I think when we started
doing this, I had a bunch
of animals in there,
and you're like, no,
we did animals last year.
So more about the flowers
and the green and, yeah,
explosion in the
river of flowers.
>> Right. I was trying to think
what was the theme for 2016.
Was that the celebrated
parks and nature or whatnot.
There might have been something
that we might have been using
to help steer some
programming and, you know,
proposed it as if there's
a way that that comes
across without being
explicit, we welcome it.
So then all of that is
reviewed a little bit
in the thumbnail phase.
>> Thomas Burns: Right.
So that all sort
of gets weeded out.
More questions?
Yes?
>> So what -- can you
talk a little bit more
about the client-artist
relationship,
this back and forth?
Like you have this idea
and then they go huh-uh,
and then you have another
idea and they go huh-uh.
What is that like?
Like what is going on there?
And how many people
are you dealing with?
Are you just dealing
with one person,
or are you dealing
with a committee?
And what is that like?
And how much are
you compromising?
Or are you trying to convince
them like well, aesthetically,
this is really more than that?
>> Thomas Burns: Right, right.
>> [Inaudible] or is it
whatever the client says?
>> Thomas Burns: Oh, absolutely.
But it depends on the client.
So in the editorial
world, something that turns
around really quickly,
like for newspapers
or maybe even magazines,
it may have a couple days
or a couple weeks of turnaround,
generally those art directors,
they say, we have this idea,
give me some thumbnails
and then we'll pick one
and then just go do it.
But you get into the book
world or the advertising world
and there's longer lead times.
Especially in the book
world and advertising,
there will be committees
of people.
And so there may be a
couple steps to get to that.
So you present a lot of
thumbnails and it goes
to maybe an art director
and they take it back
to a creative team and
then they look at it
and so they get a
lot more input.
And so things can get steered
by committees, and then that's
where that compromise
may come in, you know.
Where you say, I really
like these colors or the way
with this type fits together,
and then someone else
has another idea,
some graphic designer
on the other end,
and then you start
the sort of, you know,
kind of just juxtaposition
on how these things work
and you got to start doing a
lot of give-and-take with that.
And so it really
depends on the client.
The editorial world,
which is very fast,
I like working in that.
So if someone gives me an
idea, the thumbnails come out.
And, you know, honestly I
think giving them a lot options
up front, so that's why you
can see that in my sketchbook
where there's tons
of thumbnails.
And I really enjoy doing it.
Long ago -- and I tell my
students this all the time.
Because they'll come in with
like maybe a couple
little pencil sketches
with a stick figure.
I'm like, you need to do more
thumbnails, and they're like,
I hate them, I just want
do the final project.
So long ago, I was like
that, but then I grew
to love making thumbnails
and working out those little,
you know, the little I
guess the compositions
at that small scale.
And then that's almost like the
roadmap for the bigger thing.
And, you know, the final
piece becomes easier to do.
So I don't know if that answered
your question or not but.
Yeah, so it depends on who --
what the client or what
industry you're working for.
>> Well, I may want to ask a
little more further detail.
For instance, I did
architectural design
and [inaudible] certain scenes.
Oh you like this one but
structure wise it doesn't work.
>> Thomas Burns: Right.
>> You know?
>> Thomas Burns:
Yeah, absolutely.
>> And we have kind
of [inaudible] push them
back, push them back.
What was your feel that you
want to push your idea from
and then just back up?
What would be the weapon to use?
>> Thomas Burns: The weapon.
You hired me, I'm the expert.
Yeah, but you can't
phrase it that way.
You're just like, you know, you
have to be really diplomatic
about it and say, you
know, aesthetically --
and there's some
reasoning behind it.
So I sort of showed you the
really basic design principles,
so you can use that as
a weapon to, you know,
back up why you're doing things.
And then you can always use
other weapons of, you know,
like color palettes and
consistency and how type works.
And you can lay out
some good reasoning
about why something
works, you know.
And if it's somebody who
doesn't have as much experience,
you know, you can kind
of argue against it.
But, you know, at some point you
want to make the client happy.
And there's some
compromise at a point.
[inaudible] It is, yeah, yeah.
And you talk about the basic
principles and, you know,
it's hard to argue against that.
Say, well, this layout looks
really nice and it sort
of follows this rule of thirds.
And they're like, oh, okay.
You got me there, you know.
>> Do they try to
micromanage you then?
>> Thomas Burns: Some do, yeah.
>> To the point where,
okay, I want to put
in this texture and
you go, oh no.
>> Thomas Burns: Take that out.
Yes. Yeah, and that's, you know,
whatever art director
you're dealing with.
Some are very loose and
some are very micromanagy.
And you either like
that or dislike that.
And if you don't want to
work with somebody, you know,
that super micromanages
you, you can, you know, say,
thanks but no thanks, you know.
I have a high tolerance
of, you know, open projects
versus really closed and
tightly-done projects.
And I tend to give my students
like a really structured,
tightly-bound project
and really open projects.
And some of them just
hate the open projects.
They're like, I want
the structure,
I want the micromanaging.
Or some go the absolute
other way,
I want the little
tightly-bound thing.
So, yeah, it depends.
It always depends.
More questions?
>> When you're working in
Illustrator, Adobe Illustrator,
are all the elements that
you're working with things
that you started out --
that started out as you
drawing them by hand?
>> Thomas Burns: Yes.
So all those little tiny little
flowers, all drawn by hand.
And I know there could
be the impetus to sort
of like cut-and-paste and
sort of make a thousand
of the same flower, but then
you can really kind of tell
that somebody cut-and-pasted
and didn't, you know,
do every little flower by hand.
It just looks more natural
and doesn't look as,
you know, artificial.
So yeah, all those little
pieces, all the little pieces
of the monuments, the little
dots, the little dashes,
the butterflies, the bees, and
all that stuff is all hand done.
And then since it's so
manipulative that you can,
you know, rearrange everything
to the thousands of an inch
and manipulate it and
turn it and rotate it,
I just I like that precision.
So yes.
>> So are they scanned?
>> Thomas Burns:
They're not scanned.
Going from that thumbnail stage,
a little pen and ink stuff,
sometimes I'll scan that in and
put it next to the art board
in Adobe Illustrator,
and then just sort of use
that as a reference guide.
I know other people will lay
that underneath the art
board and draw over it.
Because they want to draw over
exactly what they did by hand.
I tend to be a little bit
more loosey-goosey about it
and just sort of start tweaking
things and manipulating things.
So that thumbnail is by no
means the absolute, you know,
Bible of how that thing
is going to play out.
Yes?
>> [inaudible] with your demos.
You showed a ship with some
humor to it with the iceberg,
and the perspective that there's
humor throughout your material.
Are there times where
you're, again,
trying to change something, the
rule of thirds or other concepts
like that, that are used
where you can manipulate that,
if you do that within your
work, it's not rule of thirds,
it's something else
because you're trying to.
>> Thomas Burns: Right.
>> Can you talk about
it like that?
>> Thomas Burns: Like that
one, that little ship.
I think there was
another one that looked
like a pill next to it.
And that's just, you know, a
straight up editorial image
like right in the middle.
I mean, that ship has
a nice diagonal to it.
So instead of, you know,
dropping it on a horizontal,
which is less interesting
than a diagonal,
that's just sort giving
that particular piece
something a little bit more
that's unexpected.
And it's not that hard to, you
know, tweak it on a diagonal.
The little pill one --
and I can maybe go back
to those really quick.
Let's have the lecture
again, in reverse.
I didn't memorize it in reverse.
And so close.
I feel like -- there.
Yeah, and that pill house
was about sort of addiction
in the suburbs, a
little editorial piece.
And again, it has a
little diagonal to it.
It could've been straight on.
But that definitely does not
play into that rule of thirds.
It just, it is what
it is kind of piece.
And that's something that
might end up in a magazine
at about a quarter size
illustration or half a page.
I think this one
was half a page.
You know, and then at some
point, you know, you can rely
on these rule of thirds and
these sort of structures,
and at some point you can do
what -- you can break the rules
and do what you want with it.
And some of my students come in
and they've already broken
the rules and they're right
in the middle of that pill house
with just one little
image in the middle.
And you know, you first start
doing this stuff with the V's
and the S's and the X's and
then you can get to that,
depending on the project and,
you know, what it calls for.
And I don't think that
needed anything more to it.
It's communicating some
kind editorial concept.
Yes?
>> So you were talking
about your process
and that you were old
school in the sketchbook.
I'm curious what you're
seeing now with your students.
Is it a basic thing to get them
to be -- to do the old school?
I mean, what direction
are they in?
Is everything going
to be computerized?
I'm just kind of curious
about what's happening with?
>> Thomas Burns: In
that world, yeah.
Yeah, you would kind of think
since computers are everywhere
and, you know, people just want
to jump on the computer
and start doing stuff.
And that's absolutely
not the case where I'm
at and what I am seeing.
There's tons of students
that, you know,
want to get the watercolors
out and get gouache paint out
and do stuff with
colored pencil.
And what's kind of weird,
I'm seeing some cut paper,
some real cut paper, not this
Adobe Illustrator cut paper.
And they are cutting stuff out
and they're gluing
things together,
and it's very tactile,
very handmade.
And then at some point, you
know, those handmade things get
into the computer, because
then you can shift colors
around way easier,
or change something,
or add typography to it.
But I'm seeing sort of a 50-50.
And at SCAD, we teach all this
sort of traditional media first,
and then -- not that these
students aren't coming in with,
you know, Photoshop skills,
but then they see how
these things work together.
It's just another tool to use.
And it can act as
traditional media.
And I think, you know, sort
of out in the marketplace,
that traditional media is prize,
and you'll see stuff like that
on Etsy and all these, you know,
websites where you see
the crocheted stuff
or the knitted stuff or
the hand calligraphy.
But then at some point it has
to go digital to be dispersed
into the larger market.
Or if it stays in that
handmade stage, you know,
it becomes a sort of more
important almost artist --
like artists' books or
paintings or that kind of stuff,
it has more weight to it.
So I'm definitely seeing both.
And that's maybe why I love
getting in the sketchbook
and doing pen and ink up front,
so I still have my
feet in both worlds.
And I think a lot of the
students learn that eventually.
Like, oh, I can use a
computer, but then I want
to work traditionally on
this project and I want
to work digitally
on this project.
So I'm definitely seeing both.
And I think that may
be a reaction to --
probably around 2000,
when computers were becoming
more prevalent in the design
and illustration
process, everyone wanted
to be on the computer.
Everything was going to be
computerized in the future.
And so then everything
sort of had this sort
of computery look to it.
And then it sort of
swung back the other way
where you'll see a lot of
the hand-done lettering.
So people are prizing that
more tactile feel to it,
more traditional look.
>> That's really [inaudible].
>> Thomas Burns:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So traditional stuff --
yeah, just like almost
like vinyl has come back.
You know, I bought
a turntable recently
and I'm buying these records.
And I'm like, this
is so old school.
Because all music is available
everywhere on the Internet,
but I'm listening to records.
And that was because
of my daughter
who got a record player.
Yes?
>> Do you have your students
turn in sketchbooks for classes?
>> Thomas Burns:
I do, yeah, yeah.
And we look at them, you know,
throughout the whole class,
just seeing what they're doing.
And some are amazing, and
some are not so amazing.
Well, you know, and
I get that, you know,
because some people think --
some students think, well,
you know, why do I
have to get in here?
I just want to get
on the computer.
And then some just love
just sitting and drawing.
And it's cathartic and it's
relaxing and you can sort
of get in the zen moment.
And I do that in my
sketchbook with the pen and --
so I'll do everything
in pencil first.
And then I go over it
with a Rapidograph pen
or a little Tombow
pen or something.
And it's relaxing for me.
And you can kind of take
some time to start inking it,
and then you're thinking about
the next thing, you know,
that you're going to draw.
But, you know, you're sort
of automatically doing this
and Netflix is on or music
is on, and then you move
on to the next sketch in pencil.
So yes, I have them turn
in sketchbooks and look
through sketchbooks, and we talk
about them and the importance
of thumbnails and doing
stuff, you know, tactically
and traditionally,
yeah, absolutely.
>> So your selection as
the artist to do the poster
in 2016 I think it was, how
has that changed your life?
>> Thomas Burns: I'm here, so
that was super cool, right?
And this is the second
time we've been here.
I was like, this is amazing.
Life-changing, this is a
big deal to have something,
you know, nationally
recognized like that,
and then to be in
the collection.
I don't know, it makes me
feel amazing that it sort
of legitimizes as an
illustrator and artist.
I'm super appreciative of, you
know, the chance to do that
and to come here and
speak about that.
>> I mean, did your
name get out more?
Was it like -- are you
getting more offers?
>> Thomas Burns: You
know, it's hard to say
if that's how people find it.
Because it's always
such an interesting path
about how people find
you as an illustrator.
Like magazine art
directors will find you
because they saw
an editorial piece
or a poster or somewhere else.
And I don't know if I
specifically ask all the time,
but I'm sure that
absolutely has something to do
with a larger awareness and
sort of marketing of yourself.
So yeah, I would say yes.
>> Can you speak to
the time involved
in even just the creation of one
of those flowers on the poster
and manipulating that program?
>> Thomas Burns: Yes.
You know, those little
flowers may take --
I mean, since they're all sorted
different, you kind of get
into a rhythm of making them.
They make take a minute or two.
Or like that bigger one that had
some more dots and squiggles,
that might take three or four or
five or 10 minutes, just to kind
of get it right, you know.
You can draw it and then like,
well, this curve doesn't look
so perfect, and you
refine it a little bit.
And then you lay down
some dots, and, well,
this dark pink is right
next to another dark pink,
let's shrink it, let's move it.
And so it just gets really
manipulative like that.
So, you know, and that
three or four minutes adds
up for the amount of
those little flowers
that are in there.
So then it starts going
into hours and hours.
And then sort of designing
that swish of the river
that sits behind it and making
sure those flowers don't run
over any awkward spots
and the green shows
through in all the right areas.
So, you know, things like
little thumbnails and kind
of drawing those might take
two or three or four minutes
to kind of get some of those.
And you can do an hour or
two hours worth of that.
And then the flowers
start getting
into the hours and hours.
And then the tweaking and
the moving starts getting
into more and more hours.
And then you're at 10, 15, 20
hours, and then, I don't know,
30 hours with the
paper and the texture.
Yeah, it just keeps
building cumulatively.
So yeah. But to me that's what
I like doing, so it doesn't seem
like it's taking a lot of time.
You know, anything that you
really enjoy doing, you're like,
this isn't work to me, I
just love drawing flowers
and buildings and
swishes and, you know,
birds and bees and
things like that.
Yes?
>> For somebody who got stuck in
the real cherry blossom traffic,
can you discuss more to your
final picture for the rest
of the questions
so I can see it?
Thank you.
>> Thomas Burns: So close.
Wait. We'll go through it again
and we'll have the
lecture again.
Wait.
Yes?
>> I was putting your
poster lovingly back
in our reading room at the top
of your talk, so forgive me
if you already mentioned this.
But were there artists who
influenced you early on?
Are there artists that
you really love today?
>> Thomas Burns: Oh, definitely.
And I did kind of
go through that,
that a lot of my art
was influenced by sort
of that mid-20th century,
the cartoon world,
the Hanna-Barbera, to
Tex Avery, you know,
the 1960-ish Bugs Bunny that
had that kind of wonky line work
and the really loosey-goosey
color.
Maybe not so much the '30s and
'40s Warner Brothers stuff.
>> That poster shows that
that you showed earlier.
>> Thomas Burns:
Yeah, absolutely.
And you can totally see
that popping through.
And then even like
people like Mary Blair.
Do you know -- she was a concept
artist for Disney like in the --
and think of like Cinderella.
And she did all this
sort of gouache painting
that has this really
light loosey feel to it.
And then if you've ever
been on It's a Small World
at Disney World and that
kind of really geometric kind
of fun kind of aesthetic
of the midcentury is her.
So you're kind of familiar
with it on some level.
Yeah, absolutely.
>> I wanted to also mention that
we've had students who come here
and draw looking at the
collection for inspiration.
We had Pixar folks here and
they had both sketchbooks
and tablets going, you know,
they were doing all of it.
It's just another tool.
>> Thomas Burns:
Absolutely, yeah, absolutely.
Yes?
>> On these, do you
get to autograph these,
or are they largely anonymous?
And is there anything
you can do --
you know, would I
know this was yours?
Is there a hidden signature
that you have worked in here?
Is there like Hirschfeld
has those schemas.
How do you not be anonymous?
How do you?
>> Thomas Burns: You'll see
a lot of B shapes in here
for Burns -- no, I didn't.
Every flower.
No, I don't think I
snuck anything in here.
But at some point there
was some autographing
of the actual prints,
the posters.
But I don't think I
put anything in there.
>> We put it in a post design
to make sure you got credit.
>> Thomas Burns: Oh, is it?
It might be on the side, yeah.
Yeah, okay.
So an after -- but
nothing hidden in there
that I'll tell you about.
I'm just kidding.
Because Lillian's here.
How dare he?
Yes?
>> If you cross your eyes,
you'll see still
see the capitol.
>> Martha?
>> I'm really curious,
did you ever study --
ever take a course on the
history of art or history
of design or illustration
in your training?
>> Thomas Burns: So many
art history classes.
I think I have an entire
PhD in art history.
Yeah, and it was, you
know, in undergrad
and in graduate school.
They give you lots of, you know,
Italian Renaissance and Greek
and Roman and Baroque and
all that kind of stuff.
So that, you know,
influences you
in some base level,
yeah, absolutely.
>> You seem to have
a theme of motion.
Do you ever take that to the
next step, theater and writing?
You talked about
animation that you like.
Maybe things of like
cartoonish, you know,
the next slide after this?
What is your experience
with that where some
of these static displays
come alive?
>> Thomas Burns: Yeah.
And so the world is
sort of moving towards
that of these things
having at least some motion.
So I actually teach a class
called dynamic publication,
which is turning
editorial pieces
into little animated gifts.
So it adds just that next little
time -- we're not doing full on,
you know, Pixar animation.
But to illustrate a point,
something else happens.
Like that little ship
would snake a little bit
around that iceberg and it
might bump into it, move back.
And, you know, just something
like that to kind of show --
it reinforces the
point of that concept.
So yeah, I've done a little
bit of that, I haven't done any
like super professional work for
magazines or digital magazines
like that, but just on
my own I've done it.
And it's a little bit
newer field to kind
of push the illustration into.
But we're trying to push
the students into that.
Because magazines and
different publications will ask
for things like that.
Like here's the really
nice editorial piece,
but can you also make it,
you know, blink or rotate
or flip around or something.
Yeah, so just a little bit.
And it's great to
have that knowledge.
It's not that hard to
take that next step.
>> More questions?
I want to ask Lillian actually,
how you run all the artists
and how you select one,
specifically one,
to a specific year?
>> So just a lot of culling
through various sources.
I think I found Thomas through
the park book or something.
>> Thomas Burns: Workbook
or something, you're.
>> Workbook.
And then just doing
the outreach.
Gaging how interested the
artist might be varies by year
that sometimes we might approach
up to three and ask them
to at least do a concept
round, where we can
at least get a sense
of how their approach
to art might then marry
with what we're hoping
to present visually.
Sometimes we just already know
who we want to be working with.
People saying, you should
work with this artist.
And I'll say, well, enough
of them are telling
us, maybe we should.
So it just varies year by year.
And then with the selection
process or the whole process
in general with the festival,
it's a little bit of a blend
of me serving the primary role
of art director and to working
with the artists, but then
having from the president
and also from a smaller
committee,
that I'll take their suggestions
and kind of whittle it
down to be enough direction
to give positive feedback
to the direction that
we want to go to,
but not necessarily
box the artist in.
Like in the case of typography,
we were open to exploring it
and then when the piece came
in, I was reminded, well,
it needs to have our logo on it.
>> Thomas Burns:
Let's get rid of that
and put the logo on there.
>> Right. So from my
perspective, we definitely try
and keep it where there's
an openness and a chance
for the artist to explore, but
also still preparing in my head,
it's the visual piece of
the festival for that year,
and so how can we make sure it's
representative of what we want
to put out to our audience.
>> What Lillian does --
she's got a great eye.
She looks at that artwork
and tries to pick out --
every year we do an artwork
-- I mean, an original pen.
I actually have the one for
that year for '16 in here
that she picked it out of there
and then the pelican
was created from that.
>> Thomas Burns: Yeah, there
was a lot of amazing merch --
the little ornaments that came
out of this were hand
painted was amazing, yeah.
[inaudible].
>> It was inspiring
[inaudible], so thank you.
>> So we are librarians and
archivists and curators.
I want to ask you, how you
are archiving your work?
And finally, as an
educator, what is your message
to the next generation?
>> Thomas Burns: A lot of
this stuff is archived sort
of digitally, but then
I do print out a lot
of these things on, you know,
acid free page neutral paper,
the giclee prints, in
a large scale format,
and then I keep those.
But I have all the
stuff digitally archived
in a couple different places.
So in case, you know, that
hard drive is destroyed
or that computer is destroyed,
all that work is
at least somewhere.
The next generation,
I would say, you keep,
keep working traditionally,
learn digital stuff as tools
and start putting
some motion into it.
And there's such a wide range
of styles and industries
and places to be drawing.
Especially in the
illustration world,
that there's always some
niche place where you can end
up working and your stuff
can be accepted and,
you know, do well in the world.
>> Any other questions?
>> So when you started out,
were you mainly using
traditional methods
or was the computer always?
>> Thomas Burns: Long,
long ago, you mean?
From graphic design days?
>> Right, right.
>> Thomas Burns: Yeah,
long, long ago --
and I don't know if you
have a background or not
in graphic design
or know anything.
It was computers had
sort of just come out,
like the little boxy
Macs, you know,
with black and white screens.
And so those were
in another room.
And like that was our goal
was to get to these things.
And so we had these pads
of paper and we were
like hand tracing typography
and putting glue on things
and pasting things
up and using markers.
And then once we get to this
black and white computer,
they couldn't do
very much, you know.
So that's where a lot of
that hand-done stuff for me
at least comes from
those basic principles.
And then getting to the -- and
I think that's a really nice way
to go instead of just sort
of jumping to the computer
and letting it do
everything for you.
However, you know, you get on
the computer and you can flip
through 1000 typefaces in a
second, instead of looking
through a book and trying to
get some Zipatone and, you know,
scratch it onto the paper.
And go, oh, that didn't work,
and throw it away
and move to the next.
Yeah, I know.
So there's a balance
between the two.
So yes, definitely.
>> Other questions?
No? So we would like to
wrap up the lecture session
and then please join
me appreciating Thomas
Burns' lecture.
Thank you.
[applause].
>> Thomas Burns: Thank you,
no thank you very much.
Thank you for coming out.
>> And you all make sure
to stop by the Prints
and Photographs division.
We displayed all the pictures --
the posters which donated
by National Cherry
Blossom Festival Inc.
Which will be around the corner
if you exit this building --
I mean this room to the
right and then make one turn
to the right and on the door,
337, you will see Thomas Burns'
like a flyer on the door.
So you don't miss it.
So please go by.
Thank you very much
for coming today.
>> Thomas Burns: It
looks similar to that.
>> Thank you.
>> Thomas Burns:
Thank you so much.
Oh my God, that was so much fun.
I really enjoyed it.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.GOV.